OTHER THAN THAT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT COMBINATIONS OUT
THERE. IT'S
BACK AT THE PANTHERS THERE'S ZA
A WRIST SHOT
>> Brian: I THINK SHOOTING THE
PARK MORE IS IMPORTANTCLEARLY
PREDETERMINED AND THE TORONTO
O
BACK AT FIVE ASIDE AND STEPPING
OUT ISJONATHAN
HUBERDEAU.
ACROSS BUT THE SHOT BY COOPER
JOE ALLOWS IT TO GO INTO  HE GO
REBOUND GOES RIGHT OUT TO
VERHAEGHE AND IT IS 3-0TRACK FR
REBOUND AND DOESN'T GET ANY
HELP FROM THE PLAYERS COMING
BACK AND THEY A AIMPOSSIBLEE EA
OF THE GOALTENDER E IS CERTAINL
NEED TO CLEAN UP.
>> Bob:
ZONE.
HE MOVES DOWNHEARD A PRETTY LOU
THE IRON.  TO DEFENSEMAN AND
THAT THEY HAD THAT
OPPORTUNITY N THERE BY KYLE
PALMIERI AS HE GOES  BOBROVSKY
IT OPENS UP THE SHORT
HERE.
>> Bob: WRAPPED AROUND SCORE.
ACCIARI.
AND NOW A CHANCE FOR BROCK uce:
THE NELSONS SCORE.
INTO AN OFFICE OF OPPORTUNITY.